I love all the people protesting
Facebook on Instagram we prove as humans
all the time how we think about privacy
which is we love to talk about it but we
don't fear it as much because the
underlining issue is the amount of bad
things that happen to the health and
well-being of our family or having our
money stolen is extremely far and few
between
you bought Facebook stock on the back of
this drop how much did you buy and why I
bought a couple hundred thousand dollars
worth of shares I'm I bought some more
this morning because I'm a long-term
believer in the stock and I don't think
there's gonna be a lot of moments over
the next three to four years outside of
macroeconomics that I'm gonna be able to
take advantage of it you know I'm I
don't tend to buy a lot of publicly
traded stocks my original Facebook came
pre IPO but when it got hit when all the
Cambridge analytical stuff happened and
Mark was on trial I bought a ton and
then obviously often this missing
numbers or news recently I've been
buying up a little bit more mainly
because I think in the next 4 7 9 13 26
years it's a good buy so it's
interesting that then that is a big pet
Roger McNamee early Facebook investor
who I'm sure you know has been out there
very publicly critical of Facebook he
compared Facebook to Phillip Morris to
me in terms of Facebook's negative
impact on the world
what about concerns about fake news what
about online hate what about concerns
about our privacy I think there is a
stunning non conversation about taking
on some sense of responsibility meaning
sure but choosing CNN or fox or MSNBC
has as many dynamics as what you're
seeing in your feed and then more
importantly what you're choosing to
consume as real I mean to me the thought
that Facebook is any different than
Twitter or Instagram which obviously
they own or websites or you know a
million different ways we consume is is
kind of laughable and silly
I mean visa and Target and the American
government itself has had breaches of
inform
far more dramatic and so you know yeah I
mean I understand the concept but I
think making you know making a jump from
Philip Morris which systematically spent
lobbying dollars and and tried to pay
off politicians for four to five decades
to suppress information is an awfully
big jump by that person okay but what
about profitability versus privacy will
one always trump the the other and can
we actually trust Facebook I mean you
know I have no problem trusting Facebook
any more than I trust any other company
on earth profitability and privacy is
kind of funny to me we choose to do
convenience over profitability every day
of the week and privacy I mean the way
we pick privacy and on a pedestal is
almost non-existent in our actions every
person watching this right now gives up
privacy every day for convenience and
speed and so whether it's gonna be
Amazon or Google or Apple or Facebook or
any of these companies that sit as a
layer on top of the internet we have
shown through our actions over the last
thirty years and and and continue to
with the usage of Instagram and others I
love all the people protesting Facebook
on Instagram we prove as humans all the
time how we think about privacy which is
we love to talk about it but we don't
fear it as much because the underlining
issue is the amount of bad things that
happen to the health and well-being of
our family or having our money stolen is
extremely far and few between what about
the forces that may be bigger than us
the fact that Russia tried to hack our
elections using Facebook and that
there's evidence that they're doing it
again to sow discord Facebook done
enough to prevent itself from being
weaponized Facebook I mean look Facebook
this Network Fox CNN Twitter it's all
the same game where I think about it
from a macro which is we make decisions
Facebook or the Russians didn't make us
pull for Trump or Hillary and so I think
that the information that people are
buying ads and running them in our
streams is very interesting because if
you look at the execution of people that
run
adds the cost of penetrating somebody
with a different opinion versus one that
already reinforces your stance is where
this starts getting far more interesting
you know I think this is one of the
great examples in human time of us not
interested in accountability Facebook
didn't make you a racist you made
yourself a racist so let's talk about
Twitter because you know you use Twitter
a lot we saw the same huge dip on the
back of Twitter earnings and it's it's
very clear that Twitter it's just not in
a high growth State they've hit a
plateau in fact they actually lost users
over the last quarter the influence is
there the President of the United States
is using you as his megaphone in my end
it's not the next Facebook yeah no but
it was never the next Facebook and like
you know the truth is Facebook is all
encompassing right with Instagram and
who knows what Mark and Sheryl and the
team is up to on their next ma or
innovation you got whatsapp yes it is
not the next Facebook I assume it's not
priced on Wall Street in the same manner
I will say this if you look very closely
to Moonpie which is a small snack brand
if you look at what Wendy's is doing I
will say that the business world is
starting to understand how to use
Facebook to drive business we're working
with Kraft Heinz on Miracle Whip it
stuns me how much Facebook excuse me
Twitter is the backbone of driving sales
at Albertsons and Walmart so I will say
that maybe the the width of attention on
Twitter is not growing to a stock
markets want the needs but the depth of
attention in the platform and the ways
to maneuver in it and its ad product
I've been over the last three to four
years quite critical and not excited
about Twitter publicly but I no question
have seen over the last six to twelve
months a resurgence different than let's
say the Trump effect of just how much
attention is in the platform when you
have attention I think you have the
ultimate currency you know to me it'll
be interesting to see what they do with
their OTT I think they should play in
that space I think they were flirting
with that a year or two ago again
you know I don't know how earnings are
done or how much the street values
things but I will say depth maybe not
with is emerging on Twitter the top five
companies by market cap are Facebook
Apple Amazon Google Microsoft in 2007
just before the financial crisis one of
them was a tech company and that was
Microsoft is the market put putting too
many eggs in the tech basket yet look
honestly and I want to be very fair for
the audience I think about things in
such long term like the thought of me
understanding the short term economics
of 90 day terms and numbers that most of
the viewers here play on and the
arbitrary nature and just the fact that
we're playing financial engineering not
actually building businesses in the
macro of course not we're not going
backwards tech companies will continue
to gain momentum let me pull it out
right here this is where we actually
live not here and so in the super long
term no in the short term I have no
sense if the market has overpriced these
companies based on what the numbers that
they can hit over the next 90 days but
like people aren't gonna be watching ABC
and NBC over Netflix right people are
not gonna be consuming newspapers over
Facebook like that is only gonna
converge uh starting in that world short
term economics and the way the street
likes to play that's up to all of you
guys but the danger in a 5 10 15 year
macro I don't see it because you know
the reality is we're only heading in one
direction which is technology doesn't
care about our feelings or our
short-term judgment or Wall Street it
just continues to advance and humans are
engaging deeper and deeper and deeper
and will continue to in perpetuity let's
talk about the long term when it comes
to Apple and Netflix you played a role
on an Apple original show that show
unfortunately didn't last that long no
blast that long
certainly not because of you when Apple
is is is is is you're doing this
original content grand experiment do you
think that they can succeed where
Netflix has when they haven't shown an
ability to do so that's far
I think the sheer amount of money that
I'm hearing they're throwing at it makes
me optimistic you know I spent a lot I
try to spend a good amount of time in
Hollywood in silicon
Valley and Madison Avenue you get a real
sense and I think the sense if you talk
to any your Hollywood friends production
and agents and things of that nature is
everybody understands that it's an
Amazon Apple Netflix Hulu and who's the
next OTT Facebook kind of world that the
network's are in deep deep trouble and
and even the cable providers and even
with mergers that sheer dollars that
these Internet companies are gonna throw
at content the NFL rights it's gonna be
an Amazon Google Facebook Apple world in
that kind of fighting for that and so
yeah I would say yes I mean I think that
programming the IP is what actually
matters in the end and when Apple not if
has its breaking bad or orange is the
new black or NFL that it will suck
people in because of the IP and the same
way that so many more people watch Hulu
and Amazon then I think a lot of people
thought they would 24 months ago
predicated on just one hit you talk
about you know I know you say you're not
an expert on short-term market dynamics
but we're all watching Apple and Amazon
in this race to a trillion dollars
Amazon sort of coming from behind in the
big picture do you see more potential in
one company or the other
oh in a substantial way I think the
Delta between Jeff Bezos and Tim Cook as
a 20-18 CEO is unbelievably substantial
and I would bet every day of the week on
Amazon why because I think Jeff has just
shown so much more ability to navigate
the end consumers attention which i
think is the ultimate value in society I
think that Tim a is an incredible guy
and I like a lot of the things he as a
human and the company is trying to push
to stand for but I you know I don't know
he's been the CEO now what seven eight
years I'm not sure you can help me with
this but I mean what earpods like well
you know I've not seen Apple win and
voice the way they should have with the
lead they had with Siri the home pods
still not out there we've not seen them
win an original program it's now been 24
to 36 months if that cat's been out of
the bag
there's been no hardware innovation
outside the earpods that has any blip of
anything and all they've really done is
we just advanced things that have been
in place prior and so I just you know at
least the way I think about the world I
don't look at it the numbers and the
ways and the short-term and maximizing
profit every 90 days the way everybody
who watches this does in the long term
what it means for consumers Amazon
through a magnitude of things has done a
far better job of mattering to the end
consumer and continues to gain leverage
you mentioned the networks are in
trouble I have to ask about CBS which is
currently deciding the fate of Les
Moonves after these accusations from a
New Yorker article about crossing a line
with women you actually stay or go
look he's guilty you should go even
after such a long and successful track
record doing the wrong thing is always
the wrong thing Emily like you're only
as good as your last at-bat or the truth
right we now don't look at Christopher
Columbus the same way we used to after
we looked carefully in all the things he
did and so of course I mean you know I'm
very aware and listen I love winning in
business too and everybody who's
watching does but if you're a human
being that's willing to look the other
way for money you're not a good human
being
so Gary you've launched a new media
men's lifestyle brand focused on the
intersection of entrepreneurship and pop
culture you say there's not gonna be any
walls there are no walls between
editorial and advertising what's the
vision here so 18 months ago I bought
pure Wow calm I have vaynermedia the
holding companies Vayner X vaynermedia
as the agency Madison Avenue Mad Men
pure Wow and 137 p.m. is the publishing
side the Conde the hearse side of things
to me you know I if you really look at
what the buzz feeds and the vices and
the refinery29 s did a half decade ago
is they kind of created publishing 2.0
where they started to do creative work
for clients instead of just buying
commercials on TV networks or in
magazines the branded content world
started to emerge and you saw those
crazy valuations for a lot of those
companies I think the continued
evolution of making content and getting
people to see it contextual that brings
the Procter and Gamble's and the Coca
Cola's value is what's going to happen
in publishing and we continue to try to
innovate on creating original
adios and apps and event marketing
things to help clients sell beer and
makeup and deodorant okay last question
how are all of these you know dynamics
that we're seeing in social media
companies impacting your investment
strategies what is hot right now and
what is not I mean look I you know a
couple ways to look at this for me and
this is just real life Facebook and
Amazon are the two stocks all in that I
believe in in a 5 to 10 year macro as
long as mark and Jeff are running those
companies I'm blindly in belief of how
they'll innovate around voice AR you
know machine learning they just are CEOs
that are willing to hurt their
short-term economics to do the long term
equity for having legacy over short term
profit I think the most interesting
thing for kind of this audience and your
show and what I grew up with in the
mid-2000s on web 2.0 and social media is
is there room for a musically or a
snapchat you know where is this next
social network and are people scared to
do it because they're scared to be a
feature and Instagram and Facebook
Twitter will copy it and slow its growth
like we saw what snapchat I'm most
fascinated will there be another social
network on mobile devices my assumptions
yes but how and then more importantly my
investment strategy is massively be of
being affected by one core thing I
believe voice devices are the next
iPhone and the apps built on top of the
Google home Amazon Alexa and Apple pod
are going to be the place where I come
out of retirement and do early stage
investing the way I did with Twitter
Facebook and Tumblr
you